well I could aggressive offensive boards  will be white is step back three that's  the right bang-bang corner nice ball  movement holding onto the droplet bank  bank with a ball movement by mark on it  timeout taken with 6:14 left to play  here in the third period 64-53 the bulls  lieutenant Jane Luol dangerous  find the one day contract will be white  spices in the church  Jewish passing told me white let that  stop him holding his speed his ability  to run the floor there wasn't a lot of  conversation about his perimeter  shooting but he just shot up really well  here he is again sauce give it to me  Kobe's not like the way he plays  understands how Vista don't cool him off  don't cool it boy